my pleasure to welcome you all along to
our july council meeting um we don't
have a chief executive today uh so i
thought i wouldn't put uh nae through
the ordeal
welcome me into the uh into the chamber
so but i think would i'd like to
commence with a an opening prayer so um
if we just take a minute for that
lord we just come before you thank you
again for the privileges that we have um
inherited as elected councillors around
this table and as we consider the issues
before us today
issues that might impact on this
community
for a long time to come we just pray for
wisdom and guidance in your name
jesus christ
amen thank you councillors we have one
apology today uh
councillor doug grant is unable to be
with us some would like to move that
that apology be sustained please
thank you stuart
thank you um clearness thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
okay any conflicts that counselors might
have at this point that they know of uh
in the agenda there's not i'm sure
you'll um mention them if they arise as
we go through the
through the meeting
right confirmation
um of the minutes
of the past meetings so
would somebody like to move the
confirmation of the minutes the ordinary
meeting of
the district council held on tuesday 14
june uh 2022 and that that that is seen
as true and correct
councillor reed thank you and seconded
uh councillor mcdonough
is there any alteration to that record
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
would somebody like to move the
confirmation of the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of council held on
wednesday 22 june
um
somebody like to move that be seen as
true and correct
uh councillor heisted
thank you councillor phillips
any alterations required
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
right that brings us on to
urgent late business and i circulated to
councillors
this morning one item that i'd like to
be considered as urchin lake business
and it is a submission on behalf of the
council
it's in draft form at this stage but a
submission for council to consider
with regard to the water services
entities bill
so the recommendation is the draft
submission be approved oh i'm sorry
would somebody like to move that that be
added to the agenda as an urgent item
thank you
against councillor reed thank you and
our second
councillor hosted all those in favor
please say hi and against emotions
carried thank you
right we're on to um adoption of the
gore district
council cemeteries bylaw
and we have a report
and the report i think keith is in your
name is it
would you like to introduce that
essentially we had
a subcommittee form to
deal with this and
we had three submitters uh one of the
submitters was really a um
operational matter so didn't didn't
that was dealt with outside of the
submission process
and the other two submitters were the
pukarao
uh cemetery trust and karen paula uh
submitted as an individual
the trust um submitted um
in person and karen uh submitted just a
written submission
um
most of the
changes requested were really around
some of the terminology becoming
consistent between the two documents and
um
some of the wording just becoming a bit
bit simpler and i think it was one or
two questions around the 60-year
term for um
sorry 60-year ownership of a of a plot
and that's
covered by the
cemeteries act so we are governed by
legislation on that one so um so most of
the
changes
uh requested were made
and i think the finished
[Music]
bylaw reflects that so yeah so i'm happy
to
okay thank you um
anything any comments says interim see
you today no
okay so um the item is open for
discussion and or recommendation
council read
i'm happy to move the recommendation
your worship and
thank mr mcroby for all the work that he
did in that and the personal contact
that he made with
some of the applicants as well
thank you
so it's moved councillor do i have a
second uh for that councillor mcdonough
um
any further discussion
any questions there's not i'll put the
motion all those in favor say aye
against the motion's carried thank you
so that brings us on to item six which
is hilber avenue water tad demolition
seems like this is
um come again from another life um and
something that we do need to consider uh
pretty uh pretty seriously at this point
so um
is
matt's not here today
okay
so matt you're on zoom would you like to
just talk counsellors through this
please
yeah thanks your worship
um yes obviously um
we've been working on what we're going
to do with the hillbilly of reservoir
for a while now
it's
well in need of replacement
unfortunately
we need to get a pipeline across the
river
before we can replace that
but as part of the preliminary
design work that we've um been doing for
the hillbilly site we've had a good look
at the hillbilly every water tower
obviously that's
no longer used
from an operational point of view and
hasn't been for some time
and
you know this
structural assessment from vicar
on to people
um at the base of the tower
um
particularly
in council workers or anything like that
and i guess probably correctly
this issue to get worse um he has
suggested that we could potentially um
try and
do some maintenance on it which would
require setting up scaffolding right to
the top of the tower
and treating
some of the spoiling concrete
that would only
i guess slow the
deterioration of the tower
and eventually
it will get worse and worse
but when considering that
we really think that it's best just
rather than spending money on
maintaining the child which has no use
currently we believe it's best to get on
into my house to tell me
um happy to take any questions
thank you man
okay so um
it is open uh for comment or question of
matt i guess the recommendation is
heading in a particular direction um
and um
really is recommending that we demolish
it at this point in time so um
counselors interested to get your views
on the tower
and the future of the tower
no any questions at all uh councillor
phillips thank you
i hope i'll start
man i just got uh
some
queries in regards to
what's going to happen or how how does
the engineers
propose to in
the new water and the old one
because we're excited
to me in the plan
i'm not sure how they're going to do it
so can you explain to me how they're
going to do the transition first of all
okay
ah no not really but i've got like
another couple of questions that um
so
building the pump station
uh where it's going to be sighted
means that you'll have to do two two
pipes
one for the older one for the new is
that right
so you have to so you're gonna have to
the money that you set aside which is
two hundred thousand dollars
is it going to put in three pumps change
all the pipeline and build the building
for two hundred thousand because that's
what you estimated it
yeah that's correct
it seems awfully cheap to me that you
know i don't think you'll be able to do
it but that's only my opinion
so
when you change the pipeline
from the old to the new
you would have had when you built the
pump station i presume that you're going
to build the contingency and that you're
going to change it over
when you change it over so you build it
at the same time is that right
that's correct
yes
okay
if indeed that's what council decision
is is to go down that track
yeah just um
to me i'm just a bit concerned about the
cost factor because we're only allowing
seven hundred thousand dollars set aside
uh 500 to remove it and then two hundred
thousand dollars for the pump station
now i don't believe that will be enough
for what the scope of the build of what
the scope is going to be
when you start putting in three new
pumps you're not going to transfer the
old pumps from the water tower to the
new pump station is that right
no we were planning to transfer them
the cost estimates are only based on
preliminary design um so once we get
into detailed design and have movement
more
work through the detail i guess we'll
have a more accurate
understanding of the cost but that's um
i guess the advice that we receive from
vicar at the moment around
the cost of the pump station um it is a
relatively
simple pump station
um so
i'm reasonably comfortable at this stage
with that cost estimate um with the
estimated cost for the
demolition of the tower we have um
talk to a local generation contractor
who's provided an estimate and we have
added a contingency to that estimate as
well so
i guess you never know
until you hit retain prices particularly
in this market with inflation pressures
and things like that
but yeah i guess that's the
numbers that we've come out with at the
moment
thank you matt and councillor heisted
yeah thanks for your report matt um
and through your worship um yeah i guess
from a government's perspective it's
pretty hard to argue when you've got a
report citing health and safety
concerns and uh
ongoing maintenance costs on a structure
that has no absolutely no use
um
and i guess the cost of demolition is
only going to increase um but i guess in
that three water space matt you've got
you've got a lot going on
is this the the next highest priority
that we do need to get on our dress i
guess just be good to get a gauge in
terms of urgency timelines
yeah so i
and guess think this is um
probably manageable and particularly so
um
the funding um that we're looking to
utilize is in the 2023
uh yeah 2023 2024 financial year um so
that gives us a favorite alert in time
to get ready
and hopefully get some of these other
major capital projects that work out at
the moment finished so
resonant comfortable
that we can
just just adding to that so in the
interim in terms of safety of people i
see you've got some catch uh
netting to catch falling debris um are
we satisfied that our staff are going to
be safe
on that site appropriately managed yeah
so
yeah so
here we have set up a few things so
we've set up an exclusion very
area around the tower um
um and we're actually just this week in
the process of um
realigning the access road into the
water treatment plant so currently the
access road um cuts up into that
exclusion zone um so having to remove
some trees which will allow the access
road to to be re-routed all the way from
the shower
so i'm relatively comfortable
um with those measures that we're taking
the pump stations the pumps and the base
the tower
and
there is no real need to
go in the air regularly to maintain
those pumps
but obviously when we go to remove them
or say for example pump broke down um we
need to put some procedures in place
to make sure that the staff can access
it safely
thank you matt um councillor reed and
then i'll ask lornae to give us some
comments around the finance the points
that uh councillor heisted raised
council reading thank you your worship
um matt just looking at the planned
location of the new pump building
how would the residents
close by
be affected by noise from the pumps
yeah so that will be
a consideration
soundproof the
stability
but not
significantly allow our plants
so again it should be
relatively easy to manage
obviously that are in the
base of the tower at the moment and we
don't have any noise issues
currently so
that is something that we need to
consider but i think that's reasonably
manageable
okay uh lunai then councilman to now
yes thank you you are shipping through
your issue um
the three-ward staff have done a good
investigation into this and they
you know they have considered the
longevity of the of the building
compared to the life cycle of costs and
the ongoing costs and maintenance um in
this instance you know over time would
outweigh the benefits of keeping the
keeping the building in there in our
opinion the funding and the long-term
plan
can be realigned for for this project so
we're
where the pipeline was due to come
across across the matilda without being
pushed out we can work with the funds
that we have and in our projects and
adjust the timelines of some of their
projects to accommodate this one
thank you lorna uh council mate now
i too have the same
the same concern as
councillor phillips that the turner
thousand is far too light
matt are the pipes close to that
building the new building are you gonna
have to do significant pipe work to get
the pipes to the pumps
or do they run
adjacent to the new building
the pipes obviously currently go into
and out of the water tower
um which is not too far away from
replacing the pump station so it's a
matter of just realigning the pipes
guardian
is there significant consultants
involved in the design of this or can
you do the design of the pipe work in
there because those costs have to be
allowed as well
yeah so um obviously the the demolition
with tower is a little bit complex and
it needs to be managed appropriate so
we've certainly um
be looking to engage some
specialist assistants with the
management of that
the pump station is a relatively
straightforward
building
and
we have got the in-house capability to
do the design
of that house
which would obviously save some costs as
well
so yeah that's probably a chance at this
stage
thank you matt councillor garland
just a question for the financing for
the um part from escort to the water
tear
for the future and also for the bridge
is that going to fall into
2023 or fall out to 24
and um
won't be a problem if it goes three
waters or are we got the horse in the
car around the wrong way um
shouldn't we concentrate on the pipeline
of the bridge first and then worrying
about the water tower second
through your worship um
yeah i can
i can answer part of that and matt can
matt can help me with that um
these are
preparatory words to help that and i
think that's they are secret issues to a
certain degree um with regards to
financing of the bridge until we know
what the appetite is and where we're
going with that we still need to push
ahead with with other projects um in
order to in order to get that across
things across the line but matt have you
got some additional comments you'd like
to
add
yeah thank you
unfortunately that's going to be some
time away
until we get the
our thinking is that we should really
get on and do
this okay uh thank you matt uh council
dixon
thank you worship just wondering what
the state of the pipes are from the
reservoir down to the river are they in
good repair
um
yeah so fortunately we've got
two fights coming up from jacobs down to
hillary
um one of them is an older cast online
and one's asbestos cement one we have
had a couple of
failures
in recent times on those just relatively
minor
but because we've got two
two names we can isolate one
from all the work
um and
yeah
those pipelines will need to be replaced
at some stage in the future but it's not
contrary at this stage
great thanks matt councillor heisted
yeah thanks russia
you know from a from a risk point of
view we've got a report stating that
there is concrete falling from a
structure potentially able to harm
public staff and contractors and i don't
think we can we can stay away from that
in terms of concerns around the budget
the budget is only the budget and we all
know that the tender price will be the
price
and it doesn't really affect their
decision today if we're looking at a
budget of a million dollars
for this project rather than a thousand
i think we're still
obliged to
to address this issue so i'm happy to
move the recommendation if there's a
segment
thank you councillor hyster for that
motion dover signature for that
councillor bulger
and and just on in light of what
councillor hai said saying and just
reminding councillors that i can't
remember the date but several years ago
we had this discussion as well i think
the cost of demolition was about 300 000
in those days
um there is no doubt that this is going
to have to come down at some point in
time and it's only going to get more
expensive so we're only putting off the
inevitable
okay um
[Music]
there's no further comments i'm going to
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
against
uh council the
guardian council of phillips
motionless carried thank you um we'll
move on then to um
item seven which is um fluoridation of
water and we have a uh a letter from
ashley beam bloomfield um regarding
fluoridation and a report from um
through waters asset manager
matt do you just want to make some
comments on this before we open it up
for discussion i think it's reasonably
self-explanatory
thank you
um yes
obviously
the ministry of health is now working
through the
implementation of the
fluoridation
have now
been instructed to a
production water supply
weren't one of those
but i guess
we
will get that direction at some stage
potentially later this year because
especially doctor ashley bernier was
suggesting
i guess it's just a matter of monitoring
and watching this space i'm happy to
take any questions
thanks matt um so the recommendation is
the report be received and the council
awaited director from the director
general of of health is there any
alteration to that councillor um
dixon thank you
so move council dixon signature
councillor guardin
is there any discussion
does not i'll put the emotional those in
favor please say aye
against the motions carried thank you
councillors
so it takes us on to the cat working
party
and we have a report here from the chief
executive
with regard to the um
the cat working party and the control
subcommittee um
chief executive's not here do you want
to make any comment lorna
yes thank you your worship um the report
is fairly much is fairly straightforward
and it's just an update for councillors
and a request to amend the constitution
um my understanding is that we've had
four
good candidates from within the
community who are keen to be involved in
the working party and the
report just effectively asks for a
council to approve the amendment of the
constitution to allow for the additional
community members
okay so we have a couple of
recommendations there with members of
the cat working party is any comments
from any of them or would somebody like
to move the recommendation council dixon
i was just going to comment and say that
yes the four people that we interviewed
were exceptional and we really couldn't
choose two out of those so
that is why we went um with the four
people and we didn't think it would hurt
to have more community input
with um with these people they've got a
lot of knowledge and experience
and i'd like to move the recommendation
okay do you have a seconder for that
council bulger thank you
thank you
i wasn't sure what the catworking party
would do actually and until uh the first
meeting and listening to
the full members of the public and
being made aware of how much work those
people were doing
and and the need there was to control uh
feral cats
um there's some people out there they're
doing extraordinary work
on on behalf of the public
unpaid using their own resources
to try and make sure that we
don't have um homeless animals running
around disease ridden so
i have to say i've had to change my mind
and i'm pleased to be a member of the
working party thank you
hi sid
yeah on a slight tangent i hope you'll
indulge me in just an issue
in the community there's the amount of
dog feces that are on lawns at the
moment if you have a walk around gore
that's pretty shocking because i want to
as a sort of a side if the if that's the
animal control department the
communications department could work on
some form of strategy to
get the word out there um i know lawns
aren't being made at this time of year
so it's probably exaggerated but
it's
more than i've ever seen
thank you for raising that um i guess we
are focusing on cats at this point but
it's a good good time to raise it
um
any other comment from councillors
council dixon
thank you worship i just want to say
that we have changed the name from the
catworking party as well
we didn't think it reflected what we
were doing
so we changed it to the cat management
group
right yes
[Music]
okay um so would somebody like to move
the recommendation
gauss grant
and seconded council dixon thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
um so item nine three waters reform and
a petition presented by groundswell new
zealand
and a report here from the chief
executive which is pretty
self-explanatory
and some of the points that they were
asking for us we had um
actually discussed at a previous meeting
but lorna do you want to make any any
comments
yes thank you russia um
the key points that the chief executive
wanted to make were that um the key
items that the groundswell had raised
were um the council hold a binding
referendum around the issue of three
waters and that the council discontinued
further funding of local government new
zealand as you rightly put at the
council meeting on the 14th of june
council
decided to
consider you know considered the local
government new zealand
membership and the fact that they still
do a lot of good work and advocacy for
council especially small councils like
or where we have no policy analysts
ourselves so they do a great amount of
work on behalf of us and one issue
should not
require us to cc membership with them on
the other front um
the
in regards to the referendum we i know
the chief executive wrote to
wrote two groundswell and
indicated this should be a national
issue and not just a local issue and i
know that we've had meetings this week
with
ministers and have raised that very
point with them and it forms part of our
a night and later in this this agenda
so the
um
from the council's perspective
i believe we've done all that we need to
we can note that we've received the
petition um it does meet our
requirements for petition we staff have
not had the time to verify the
signatures on that
but we believe that we've
acted appropriately in response to the
petition to date
thank you lorna i think you cover the
points pretty appropriately
um as
i mentioned we do have a another item
which will be considered an urgent life
business in 1915
which relates to water reform as well
and does
address some of the issues that um the
grounds will have raised here
but um
if there's no further comment would
somebody like to move the recommendation
councillor reid said councillor macphail
all those in favor please say aye right
against the motion is carry thank you
right we move on to item 10 and we have
the annual residence survey which was
quite voluminous i'd have to say and in
its presence in our agenda a lot of
really good information um a lot of good
work happening within the council and in
some areas where we need to
up our game as well but certainly
the result is uh pleasing overall
um
sonia do you want to make any comment
before we open it up for
councillors to talk about
uh thank you worship and and through
your worship i suppose the civil results
are reasonably self-explanatory that
they um follow the usual successful
format we have had previous years again
we've had a very good uptake from
residents um
wanting to be involved in it i suppose
one of the things that is of note this
time around is our public toilets which
always
fear rather badly and we don't meet our
performance target on that and yet it is
the second highest used by those who
answer the survey so they're very
popular
maybe something counselors want to think
about when it comes around to an annual
plan or long-term plan time um because
there obviously is ongoing
dissatisfaction with public toilets but
apart from that as the me mentioned it
is reasonably positive
happy to answer any questions
thank you okay so the
the report is open um for discussion
uh
and or recommendation
in comments uh counselor dixon yogas
ready to say something
well i i just wanted to comment
basically because i think
i saw the knowledge of the district plan
was very
that a lot of people didn't understand
what it was and i think we sent out a
brochure that every
body receipt regarding the district plan
we didn't
okay
so
i was interested in that and also the
needs of the community i mean
we've we've come
the percentage of people who are happy
with
how we portray ourselves has really
decreased from
um
2014 was 86 and now we're down to
66.
um concerned about the toilets as well
and i'm wondering what happens with this
survey what
we do the survey year after year and
there's some things that come through
like
council
being
easily contacted for different issues so
what do we do about that and the
satisfaction of people
well i guess um my understanding is that
all the
all the comments uh are in various
groupings and each of the departments of
council
are given those
those comments and and that will form
the basis of the work for the coming
year
um
am i right from that
uh yesterday that is the case all
managers have had a chance to read the
comments and comment on it but it can
also provide counsellors with direction
on where we're to focus priorities as
well so you can see what the hot topics
are within the community and focus
accordingly going forward with annual
plans and long-term plans
council guardian council mcfarland and
councillor hosted
just a comment on the local gravel roads
it's moved up two percent and we it
started that meeting with peter
last year and we're meeting quarterly
and we're hoping to have some outside
people come in i just wonder if murray
is going to continue with that
because i think that helps get the
community involved and get that
information flowing both ways
can you give us a bit of an update on
that murray
that's very
that's very definitely um
the intention to resume those and that
should be resuming within the next month
we're just currently
busy with the ncta end of year
reporting and final claims as soon as
that's over we'll um we'll
organize
another meeting
thanks murray um councilman mcphail
yesterday worship um
obviously there's some great uh great
results here for some of our amenities
and um obviously credit to the people
who are doing that particularly around
the library um swimming pool event
center that sort of thing
it's good to see the community is uh
recognising that particularly
uh identifying the fact that we've had
some very difficult conditions to work
under and keep those going um
councillor
guidelines actually brought up the
second part of my statement was
in regard to those sealed roads yes we
have we have started that and i think we
don't want to lose that emphasis where
all the people that are contact with the
rural
ratepayers will still be getting the
emails
and the contact regarding some of the
satisfaction levels there
murray and we did have that working
group going and we were making some
slight inroads
into working through some of those
problems and i think um probably the 68
satisfaction
and a slight increase here i think we've
done reasonably well
out of that but there's still
a lot of work to be done
so
yeah thank you council mcfarlane and
from memory i'm not just having my
finger on it right now but i think in
the peer group with regard to gravel
roads and seal roads we were
the top or second top uh in terms of
satisfaction with other councils um so
it yeah there's work to be done um but
it's certainly better than where it was
yes and it's it's obviously a difficult
one with budgets and obviously
increasingly a contracted cost as well
so we do recognize that but um
overall good effort
thank you councillor hosted then
councillor reed
you thanks for worshiping probably three
years on you just the public toilet
issue you raised i guess i'm looking at
the the attachment and while usage has
dropped
satisfaction
with those facilities is in that 80 91
37 range
so
it probably wouldn't surprise me that
residents may not use
public toilets
is it a satisfaction issue or is it a
uses issue
through your worship
so the results show that um of the 600
over such over respondents 286 of them
said they had patronised a public tool
in the last 12 months which is probably
reasonably high
well it's the second highest of all the
public council facilities and yet the
public satisfaction with that is the
lowest and has been the lowest for a
number of years
does that answer your question
so i'm
you know a lot of people use them but
they're not very happy with them
so 88
is taken as
it's unsatisfied 88
of the total sample is satisfied
with public toilets that is an all-time
low
has it drifted
down
i would have to
if you look on
the page satisfaction with facilities
yeah yeah so it just has the number of
people who use the facility
and then the amount of satisfaction with
it but as we're not missing our kpi
level which is 90
yeah
so it's i suppose it's the only one that
doesn't mean it's kpi
councillor reed and then councilor
phillips
thank you your worship um i i think it's
pretty good overall actually i'm just
looking at the numbers and particularly
amongst the library and aquatic centre
where most of our people who would have
answered that survey
would have most use
and one thing i will
acknowledge too is that our front office
staff have just recently been placed
sixth in a
um was it local government
um and that that's pretty amazing for a
small town to have
you know a front office come up with a
number like that i'm really impressed by
that the other comment i'd like to make
regarding the library there is a in one
of the paragraphs
that says
one of the things that the public didn't
like a small minority expressed
dissatisfaction with losing the large
james coming wing hall and i think with
the new community
rooms involved with the library project
we just need to remember that there will
be some big
rooms there that are available to be
made either smaller or larger for
different sized venues to be gathering
i'm just hoping that
perhaps we might just need to remind the
public about that
thank you
thank you uh councillor phillips
thank you worship which isn't regarding
the toilets um
the dispection of the of the residents
is it because of its cleaning ability or
the facility itself because going
forward
do we set aside money for more cleaning
or do we set aside money for the
facility itself and upgrading the
facility is there any
thing on that
just through your worship just looking
at the survey results one of the
comments that we have picked out here is
that having clean public toilets is
important when you're traveling so that
perception of clean cleanliness is
probably one of the things um i honestly
couldn't comment further unless i went
through the verbatim comments which i
think the council's received report
so the toilet expert keith do you like
any comment
oh neil sorry
the public toilet
the biggest change i believe over the
last few years is perception of what
people perceive
as a public toilet a lot of republic
toilets
the concrete block
etc were ideal several years ago but
people now perceive they want the clean
tile
aspect
the cleaning
regime has
increased um really over the last 12
months
we've increased that
and
i understand the survey but when only 47
have used the toilets at least once in a
year
they haven't really used public toilets
some of those public toilets have been
cleaned three times a day
but we still get complaints
and
the cleaners leave them clean
and
something can change in three years
quite easily
there are some of the toilets in
for example
hamilton park
it's going to have to get replaced very
shortly because it's on a lane
on the old landfill
and we're just taking measurements
structurally it's still sound but it's
going to cause problems in the pipe work
very shortly
and one of my
things on my list over the next year is
to do an audit of all the toilets so we
could put actually report in front of
you councillors as to what we do have
and what uh state they're in as far as
structurally and
what we supply in each toilet
the
overall satisfaction
anecdotally
people are quite pleased with the
cleaning and that of the toilets
and in the last two years
when the first lockdown during covert we
were one of the few that kept toilets
open for the
road transport industry
and
after the first few days have increased
to other towns on the on the main state
highway et cetera so
they were maintained all through but as
i say it is the perception of what
no talk i could honestly say that no
toilet and gore here is as flash as what
some of the city malls have got in their
shopping centers
but is that what people expect
thank you neil
and congratulations and thanks to the
work that you and your contractors and
team do to
to manage the toilets uh it is a hard
task and it's a hard ask
um there's some pretty high standards
expected by
the travelling public but also our local
road players in terms of the standard of
those toilets and the points you make
about
clean three or four times a day
is a good one so um
needs to be born in mind when we're
looking at these figures
okay other
comments or questions council dixon
thank you worship i just noticed that
waste and recycling is quite high on the
list of dissatisfaction and i'm i'm
actually wondering what's happening with
our
um
waste the group because we haven't met
for some time
so um
do you want to make a comment on this
one sonia i know there's the rethinking
waste group is about to meet soon
and
the person that we'd engaged to help us
with that had been away for a period of
time as well so so yes there has been a
bit of a hiatus there um but certainly
it's an area that people are taking an
increasing amount of
interest in and it's something that we
need to get right
yes through your worship that's that's
correct um the consultant that um the
former writing manager engaged for this
project dr nikki bold went back to
england for a while so um she'd carry
out a bit of community
conversations prior to that um i think
councilman fail you may be involved in
some workshops and some online
conversations um and there is a meeting
scheduled
for the next couple of weeks i think
just for her to come down and make some
presentations and progress start pick it
back up again
yup
counselor bulger
no we're talking about waste we're not
talking about recycling
51 of
respondents are not happy with um
the opportunity to recycle
okay that's fine but
central government
have not produced the facility
uh for us to send any recycled private
product
and um
while you know we have to take note of
the survey
i don't think we should beat ourselves
up when central government you know what
what do we do with the stuff
you know and um
look i know
purists amongst the recycling community
you may well be one you worship will be
aghast
by the fact that the recycling is just a
very costly frustrating exercise
and i don't think anybody in new zealand
is managed to achieve their aspirational
goals so
um
look it has to be state of the game
central government they've got a partner
play they've dropped the ball it's again
we've got nowhere to send this stuff
thank you for indulging me that's right
councillor bulger and look i totally
agree with a lot of the comments you
make
but it's no getting away from the fact
that people are looking for local
leadership in this area
and they're looking for
options for themselves to be able to
recycle but also to minimize waste and
the shift the shift in terminology seems
to have
moved on since the last time we were
having this discussion from simply a
recycling discussion to what do we do to
minimise waste overall counselor um
dixon you're going to make a comment
thank you worship you just answered that
question waste minimisation is where we
should be heading
not the end result
counselor thank you for the clarity
yes uh just
in regard to one of those queries
regarding uh nikki
bolt
who's been doing the
rethinking waste project
we have got information as of yesterday
looking at how to progress
releasing some of the information she's
just working out how we'd do a
presentation to council or a more
detailed report to council was a
preliminary report out
and
as council bulges
indicated obviously recycling but
recycling when we look at the
hierarchical
repurposing of rubbish is about uh
second from the bottom so there's a
number of different stages before we get
down there but uh i do appreciate what
he's saying because it is a major
major thing we identified in there that
we don't have facility in new zealand
for the type of plastics and in class of
plastics
the nearest ones are actually in
australia so
yeah we do have our hands tied yup
thank you council mcphail
right um
with regard to the annual residence
survey is there anything else any
counselors would like to raise at this
point in time
if there's not would somebody like to
move that that we received counselor um
reid seconded councillor mcdernell thank
you all those in favor please say i
against the motion is carried it brings
us on to item 11
and that is a pre-election report and we
have a memo here from the chief
executive
and this is a statutory requirement
for the member for the chief executive
of each of the local authorities to do a
pre-election report prior to each
triangle election
and the purpose behind that is to really
give
readers and ratepayers alike
a snapshot of where
this community sits where its focuses
are and its performance and its aims for
the for the future so risks and
opportunities
assets and liabilities so certainly i
think um
steve has done a particularly good job
in this one some very interesting
reading in there and it's very clear
and and i found pretty understandable
but
open for discussion and or
recommendation
council read
i'm quite happy to move the
recommendation your worship it's pretty
straightforward
thank you do i have a second for that
council davis thank you
uh any further discussions not put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
brings us on into item 12 um gore main
street uh tree replacement
and a report here from um parks and
recreation manager keith do you want to
talk us through this report keith um
certainly these look
pretty exciting
and the work you've done tonight and
tidying up some of those trees that have
been a problem for some time as
is a critter to you and your team
yep through
your worship um
i think last year um i just sort of come
on board when
presented a report
regarding uh replacing some of the trees
on the main street
i think there's a general agreement that
the
dawn redwood uh species is not suitable
for that location
um so it's really just um carrying on
with the program of works and um i think
the work
i think we did three trees this year and
um
it's probably been a bit of a learning
exercise uh with some of the technology
we've used and
i think we had one covert sort of shut
down during that period so it just made
the process a bit longer
um some some of the products we've been
using too come from australia
so again we were
it was a bit of a supply issue there so
um
hopefully going forward i think there's
11 trees remaining
and the proposal is we do the um
the top end of the main street will
finish that area off first which is
another six trees and then
and then there's another five trees
remaining the following year
thanks keith um so open for discussion
and or recommendation councillor reed
i'm happy to move this
recommendation as well but i'd also like
to say that
i particularly like the new guards and
the fact that the planting themselves
are a little bit further out from the
retail premises
and our retailers have really been very
patient over
many years about the cleanup they've had
to do with the dawn redwoods
the only thing is i note that you want
to have
the tree the new replacements in prior
to christmas
is there a real certainty around that
because that would be the last thing
they need at the moment would be
to have disruptions on the main street
through that time
just to comment to your question
i think in terms of timing
we're dictated
uh we have the
plants on sort of standby that's the
easy part um some of the materials again
we're dictated by um
outside suppliers but um i'm i'm happy
to sort of do it in the autumn
uh 2023 um just to
keep people happy really
thank you thank you keith i think it's
important that if the materials and the
and the plants are here and time to do
it well before the december busy period
then that that's fine but if they're not
then i think believing it till the
autumn would be a a good move so um are
you moving that brahman though moved and
councillor heisted yeah thanks for
having a second man and i i guess um
several years ago councillor davis and
councilman bulger and i were placed on a
hearings panel to to navigate um this
issue because there there was an
agreement with the parks reserve manager
to see these trees removed so
we
basically our hands were tied and we
couldn't respond to the issues that the
retailers were facing so
delighted that a practical approach has
been taken here when it's and it's being
addressed and those those leaves are
absolutely terrible so good good work
keith
thank you so it's moving senator council
dixon you wanted to make a comment i
just just to comment i'm just wondering
if because these the um tree specimen is
deciduous
there are going to be leaves that will
need to be cleaned up is that going to
be an issue
just a comment regarding the tree it's
um
it's
probably what you would call a
medium-sized tree as opposed to a large
tree
and um
i think the dawn redwood um
has a particularly fine leaf that blocks
gutters
so i hope
i guess
our hoping is that there won't be a lot
of leaves going in gutters and
the leaves on the street we can
yeah we can clean up just just as we do
currently so
great thank you
any other comments or questions of keith
if not it's been moved and segmented
i'll put that motion all those in favor
please say i'm against the motion is
carried thank you counselors
right we'll move on then to item 13 one
that's visited this table before
as well
the charging structure for the tipping
of green waste at our transfer station
and we have a
report here from the chief financial
officer that's running us through what
the options
might look like um
for the changes that that we had
suggested so juane do you want to just
roll this one out yes thank you
reshaping through your worship it's um
as you have mentioned this has been to
the table many times
and it is something that i have
inherited
um
but at the at the 14th of june council
meeting there was discussion around
what staff intention of the report was
and what council has understood so
staff have gone away and performed
additional analysis we've looked at a
larger period the previous report had
looked at two months worth of data we've
now looked at 10 months and analyzed
that and also annualized it so in the
table
we've shown two scenarios the scenario
of what the original intention was and
the scenario of what councillors
had thought they were
thought they were improving
and so you've got scenario a which is
all loads under 100 kgs are free
from 101 kgs it's considered a bulk load
and therefore charged from zero so
effectively if it was 120 a ton it would
be 12 and 12 cents for 101 kgs scenario
b is that the first 100 kgs of all loads
are free so it means that 101 kgs
somebody would be charged 12 cents
and charging would go up from there
so
staff are wanting indications from
councillors about the direction that
they want this to hit um and what covers
what costs are willing to
be covered by council and what should be
covered by fees and charges
thanks lorna um
who's going to lead the charge on this
one councillor hosted
i hate to suggest this may need to come
back to council again but
just based on feedback that i've had in
since the last meeting from the
community and also looking at the
resident residential survey
i think we need to reflect that one of
the reasons we
held the green waste charges was around
recycling that we could only recycle
glass
and at this point we're still only able
to do that
and also
um we don't
uh necessarily have a solution on how to
handle the green waste in matera
so i i'm at this point feeling that it's
a good opportunity to perhaps pause on
the residential use charges
at the transfer station until we both
have a solution for materia
and some form of progression around
around recycling or waste minimisation
the yellow bins are just receiving glass
at the moment
and i think
i could be guilty as as well at the
table of not recognizing that it wasn't
just a covered
pause it was also a
in response to a change in level of
service and recycling so my suggestion
and and
might be premature to move it would be
that we we pause for 12 months on the
charging of green waste for residential
users i think commercial and out of
district users while difficult to manage
install the charging regime should still
be in place
okay um
thank you
thank you council high set are you
moving in that direction
you're opening the
discussion perhaps i should move and
then the discussion can follow so i'd
move that the recommendation be changed
where it says for all users for
residential users
and delete commercial in our district
from that recommendation
okay so um
right so it's
new do we have a second for that
phillips thank you i'm sorry sorry no no
i've got that totally wrong it's
introduced
sorry for
all users to be deleted commercial and
our district users should be
in the recommendation my apologies
okay so just can you just clarify that
again just run it past me the council
introduced free
uh
green waste charges for the first 100
kgs at the refuge station
for
reasoning for commercial on our district
users with the effect from one august
and that the cost is opposing the green
race over the 100 kg threshold be
charged
on a weight basis of 150 percent
right that makes sense so you're happy
to second that now
i i actually thought you were removing
the district ones because i have a
concern with that
the charge i withdraw my second the
charges in place for commercial and out
of district
free for residential
for google residents of course yeah i
understand them i still have a concern
with the out-of-district ones because if
we're cheaper
then then somewhere else they're all
going to come here
and that's that's the problem i'm going
to have because it's costing us 84
we're not not going to get the return
to be clear
gore
district residents
will have no charge for green waste
commercial and out of town users will
over 100 kgs that's yeah i understand i
understand that but the thing is that i
have concern is that
they out of district users may use us
because we're cheaper than taking it
somewhere else
so
yeah okay so
you're withdrawing your secondary
okay so is there anybody else willing to
second that council
council of bulger
oh okay is there any other seconders out
there
okay so at this point it lapses for one
of a seconder so
councilman fail and then council bulger
yeah i think we just want some um
clarification in regard to that because
um i probably would
possibly second that as long as we
understand
i know what counselor phillips is saying
in regard to commercial
um and also setting it aside at present
because we've still got our
waste management plan that's coming
through and there's still going to be
changes within that
and i think if we actually have this set
aside
continue with the structure
which i believe
council heisted stated
was over 100 kgs for commercial
and uh
uh non-residential
so they will be paying for that
i know they still get the first hundred
uh
case
free 100 kilos free
but we still have our residents coming
in at free that the understanding there
if that rides through until we work out
under our new waste management or the
discussion document that's coming to
establish whether we have any other
system that can that could possibly come
into play
to assist us um
i think it may be a short term remedy
not not for long term
okay um is that clear or is it still is
everybody and even further everybody
clear on that i think it's just been
explained a slightly different way to
what council hosted was talking same
thing
um
councilman
and then council dixon how do we know
who's an out-of-district
person
that's your big problem yeah i think
that's probably one of the questions
i've have how how will that be managed
at the the weighbridge
um how would somebody know where this
particular individual comes from
and because there will be people that
push the
and push the rules push the boundaries
councillor phillips thank you sorry
council excellent was next
thank you worship
um look i've been having some in-depth
discussions with some of these people
like mr green people who
been on my
radar
um and i went and had a look at a
trailer for one garden in a trailer full
of leaves and wet weeds because you
can't garden at the moment without
bringing out earth
and that
trailer load would be probably worth
about 500
kgs so the first 100 kgs would be free
but then they'll be charged
on the next 400 kgs which
could add quite a loss and they'll have
to pass that on
and they're talking about their elderly
people
i can't see how we can't charge five
dollars per single axle trailer seven
for a double axle trailer
and then um in maybe a car load five
dollars
and trucks
on there on their weight over five ton
because that would be a heavy vehicle i
i don't know if that's another option
but
i know this is probably going to be an
issue that's going to be raised and a
lot of our elderly people can't
be mowing and doing their own gardens so
are we
going to put um this cost on to them
which is would be disappointing
okay i i guess um
if if they're residents and the waste is
is theirs and it's under 100 kgs they're
free the issue is who's delivering it to
the to the transfer station and how do
we identify that
i understand the issue um
council uh phillips and then councillor
bulger
thank you guys
and also as bret councillor high seat
had said that uh matera has not yet been
discussed
uh we haven't had a report about what
what will happen in matera uh in regards
to the green waste
and i and i believe what will happen is
that
as council addiction just pointed out
that maybe
the last load on the friday of a
commercial business will probably wait
till one o'clock on a sunday and come to
mater and he put it out and that's
if i was them that's actually what i
would do
counselor bulger yes i have a question
for lorna if i may
if
we don't adopt this charging racing
what's the impact on the bottom line
yeah thank you um you're worth shipping
through your um news council bulger to
put things into perspective
what we're taking from commercial
rate payers currently and the 10 month
set was under um under review was only
13 000
that puts it into perspective we've had
no loads up around the five five ton
we've had some in the one one and a half
tons for large commercial users but the
majority of our loads fall below that
100 kgs over 50 of their loads fall
below the 100 kgs for commercial users
well for for all users but but yeah for
the commercial users what we've got for
as far as charges are
at 13 000. that's what we're taking for
in relation to green waste in a 10 month
period
so the cost to council currently is
around 234 000 so we
we add 220k
in the hole before we even make any of
these changes
um
to put it
mildly bluntly
council bulger
we're not santa claus
no we're not santa claus if if the users
don't pay for it somebody has to pay and
it'll go on the general rate or wherever
so
you know i've got sympathies for
councillor dixon but um we've just got
to be aware that we we're not santa
claus um
i i guess the the issue and it's um
it seems to get complicated every time
we we talk about it at a council meeting
is just where is the fair boundary
where's the where's the lines
um but i'm interested um
councilmaker now and then counselor
guardian
i think we've struck a pretty fair
system here and i think people with
green waste
if you've got a large section then keep
it at home
you can pack it under trees or make up
something that you can compost it and
it'll rot down
that's the you know this idea of taking
everything to the dump i want a
perfectly clean section well get over it
and put some bins at the back of the
section and store the stuff and it'll
you know you'll get it packed down i've
got my farm two week compost bins the
amount of stuff we put in those and it
just packs out of sight so just go and
buy some weak bins no bigger than this
table and put the stuff in it and you'll
be fine
okay um council garden then counselor
hosted
i think councillor mcdowell recovered
for those well because what was covered
is what i said the only thing is if to
be really fair you got to charge every
load that goes to the tip
and that's that's the crunch of if you
want to put up user pay on you've got to
start from
zero
calcium then council davis
i guess i guess the point we're missing
on this though is that is that when
the recycling service reduced to glass
only we did not reduce the the charge to
rate as for the yellow bands
and at that time as a council we said
it's a covert situation
we can make a concession there and
there's a and there was uh so yeah sorry
during the cover situation and in light
of that
we would waive the charges for green
waste so the commercial users were
already paying some form of charge to
use to dump their green waste so to say
that now they're going to have to charge
the users
which suggest they gave their users a
discount when we waived the greenways
charge which i don't i don't know
so i guess i may not have explained it
very well but we currently are providing
a lower level of service for recycling
it's a pause my suggestions are pause
until we can at least bring some
solution forward to the community um but
commercial and out of town
um that's for the weighbridge operator
to work out
yep okay
all right council davis in council
mcphail
i'm with councillor bulger on we're not
santa claus either so it is costing
council significantly
to do this regardless and we need a
solution
quickly this can't go on
because we're digging a larger hole
every year that this carries on and
we've got to find the money from
somewhere else so the ratepayers are
actually paying for this
in a roundabout way anyway
you know council high seeds saying that
because we're offering a less service
we're
going to not charge at the transfer
station but not everybody uses that so
everybody that
is still being charged for the yellow
bins isn't necessarily benefiting from
the transfer station so the swap isn't
equal
so
i'm perplexed as to why we're offering
this free at all
because we're digging a larger larger
hole financially every single month that
goes past
and the ratepayer in general is paying
for this through the general charge
anyway
so
i think we we need to
go back to the drawing board and start
from scratch i think yeah that's what i
think yeah so so i guess in many ways
you're right um councillor davis
whether the user pays or
the rate payer pays
the rate payers are ending up paying
um councillor mcphail
it's
three worship just really in response to
some of the discussion relating to where
um the the waste management or the
recycling waste management group are
looking at and part of that in regard to
the financial side of it was looking at
um how we could actually obtain some
money back into the council or community
via levy that uh we currently pay quite
large levees which are increasing over
the next 12 months another 12 months
and it does involve what how we deal
with obviously glass management
waste and the other various uh waste
management groups and
you know there is financial recourse
that we can look at so it's this is not
the the end of the line that if we put
it over the tip face or into our waist
waist area
um that we have to wear all those costs
so that is part of that
review process
okay so we've been around the table
many times on this one not just tonight
but previously so
i'm gonna allow people to speak once
more and then i want either a motion or
we'll move on to the next item
so counselor dixon
thank you worship um i think we should
go back to the drawing board and and
charge everybody for their green waste
because as councillor davis said
ultimately we are all being charged for
it anyway
okay
uh who else anybody else want to um make
any comment
does anybody else want to put forward a
motion at this point in time
do you want councillor davis i'll put
for the motion that we go back to the
drawing board and start afresh
and we look at charging everybody
appropriately
whatever that level is
but it has to be
a reasonable amount that we charge
so i guess that that means that the
working party um rethinking waste will
be the ones that will bring that to the
council for decision next time so what
you're visiting
is there a sector for that
secondary council guard on thank you
um so in the meantime
things stay the same as they are
yeah
so what what time frame do we look at um
if we maintain the status quo for how
how long until we actually adopt it if
you had that in the motion then we could
possibly you know six months review or
um
so we can actually get the rubber on the
road
okay would you like to put a um a
timeline in that council davis
well
we need to work in with your schedule so
what's what's the schedule
i think probably the suggestion of six
months is going to give that review
committee some time to come back to
council
it's going to be tight
but i think it was going to take at
least that by the time
there's good consultation and engagement
with the community on what the options
might look like we'll put six months
then
council heisted but just to clarify what
is the interim situation
so
i guess at the moment um green waste is
free for all residents
um but not for commercial users
is that right
almost three years
so
small small loads are free um but larger
trailers um do carry a charge uh so
those charges will probably still be up
on our website and at the transfer
station at the moment
so there is still a complex
complex calculation won't because
ultimately what we want is something
simple for the staff down there to
operate and so there's no judgment
involved
right councillors understand where we
are and and i know that there will be
approaches from
some people some individuals uh to
counselors after this um after this
discussion but i'll put that motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
i think
um
and i guess well
the issue that council
heisted raised right at the beginning
is is pretty important and and has to be
part of that discussion is what what
occurs in matera
going forward as well
um right we move on then to the minutes
of the matera community board meeting
and we have the chair of the community
board present welcome alan it's good to
good to have you here
um
so the minutes of the minute to be
received and recommendations contained
within
um
ratified so would somebody like to
either move that or ask some questions
so counselor phillips moved that the
recommendations uh both of them be
received and acted upon councillor um
reed thank you
is there any further discussion there's
not all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you
okay so that brings us
to item 15.
and uh councillors i shared a um
a draft submission with councillors last
night uh for the council on the water
services entities bill
so hopefully everybody's had a chance to
to read that and and understand it
so
i would like to
put that
forward
for councillors to consider now
and the recommendation is that the draft
submission be approved and forwarded to
the finance and expenditure select
committee for consideration
is there any comment or questions
from councillors on that submission
i've also asked that we
have the opportunity to speak
to the
to the select committee and that would
happen in
i know that each of the other
authorities in southampton are going to
be asking for a select committee hearing
to be held in this part of the world
council heisted you thank you worship i
think uh yeah good good submission and
certainly i think the table supports the
the need for a a national
referendum on the issue
so um and that's the main thruster there
of our report so yeah well done
okay so are you prepared to move that in
the yes okay
so move council high state secondary
council read thank you
is there any further discussion
councillor um dixon oh thank you worship
i just wanted to ask i think it's a very
well written letter
um and i fully support it but is is it
confidential or could it go on our
um website i'll go on the website it's
being discussed in the open now so so as
of now it's um
it's in public
great
okay if there's no further discussion
i'll put that motion all those in favor
please say i
against the motion is carried
right counselors that brings us to the
end i think of the open agenda all right
there
um
so i'll move that we go into committee
uh to discuss a number of items
um
that are listed